[Music]
last Thursday night game of the year Oh
week 15 playoff pictures coming into
focus Simpson I have no idea if we made
or lost money this week and Sims as Phil
oh we know we know I know what I did I
know I lost money that is a hundred
percent yeah you're probably right
I don't even think I had a good week
even picking just who won the game I
mean if you wanted to be honest about it
I picked the Panthers and win a close
one I picked the bills the win a close
one
I picked the Falcons to win a close one
I picked the Texans to win a close one
yeah I picked the ravens to win a close
one
pick the Patriots the blow I'm out yeah
pick the Saints to win a close one yeah
you didn't do great pick the Jedi won't
work out to blow them out and they blew
him out speaking of the best one their
Raiders and Steelers I just saw this on
Pro Football Talk NFL Draft heading to
Las Vegas 2020 2020 let me tell you
something that would be a blast what are
you guys doing April 2020 our players
are rested before they actually get in
the league I was gonna say April 20th oh
honey 20 smoke you're gonna have to
dress like right around there perfect we
might get a Laremy Tunsil the week of
the Dhruv today on the drive in the
green room all right so I'm not even
kidding the film notebook this week is
really really good I had a chance going
through it s LFL update if only we were
not PPR we would be advancing but
instead Kyle Rudolph two catches seven
yards enough to beat Odell Rogers by
point nine points what's PPR point per
reception we made it through a whole
fantasy season and you don't know what
PPR is oh yeah so because he got two
points for each of those catches right
Congrats on making it through your first
fantasy see ya well done Don managing
the team left go it does suck
keeping Washington's defense in there
was a bad decision yeah Odell was the
one we were thinking about no that was
my other Lee whose
other demons we get a gauntlet on Sunday
I could have scooped up somebody yeah
but it's okay it's alright it was a good
season oh no you know what again
Odell not playing in our playoff game
kinda hurt us yeah Rogers I want to
apologize to the fans Sims and Lefko
because when we were doing our podcast
on Monday I was using the iPhone alarm
to transition between games
oh god this is that realization that
everyone uses the same alarm sound and
we're all just humans that succumb to
Pavlov's dogs theory that I know
Pavlov's dog theory really throws me for
a loop
everything will cause a reaction right
and so people hear that sound and that's
their sound that get the F out of bed
that's their sound that's like you've
just now burnt your chicken so
apparently a lot a lot of people tweet
us and message us and be like like the
shot clock idea please don't ever use
that sound effect again because it made
them upset it made them frantic they
panicked when they heard it so so we're
gonna have to just we'll do like a fart
buzzer oh yeah will change the noise oh
we got to be a little more mentally
strong Simpson left all its listeners
self Scout the self forgot scout the
listeners they got to be able to
overcome some obstacles every now and
then okay sometimes the crowds a little
louder than you like okay so really
we're preparing them for the play we're
preparing them for that's what we do I
as you could tell from that cough coming
down with something apparently you are
scouring the office for emergency I was
I just trying to get ahead of having you
just pounded me that was a bad I know
but trust me I kind of give it a light
one that I give I'll get some hand
sanitizer mid pocket all I've consumed
for the last two days is soup yeah
that's it yeah that's thanks man I'm
sorry I just it's okay there was a lot
of people coughing in the studio
yesterday I knew it was gonna happen to
me eventually yeah it's around I know my
kids have had it it's I had it I hope I
just don't get it again that's what
happens to me with no spleen I will get
the same sickness again like a month
after I've gotten better if you're like
the Sean McVeigh of sickness it's the
same thing just different very very good
you get jet sweep flu right he got jet
sweep flu last week I am I'm telling you
guys
let me let me tell you something when I
get to the Rams Bears film notes with
Simms I was reading it going oh [ __ ] the
NFC is up for grabs so that's a little
tease ephedra cue to go through the
holiday schedule for the next few weeks
yes so just to let everybody know what
our schedule is looking like the next
few weeks I have this in a spreadsheet
which has been shared with Moses you
benefit of working with vendrick is that
a lot of people go I don't know what's
gonna happen over the holidays and
Fenric goes I got it all figured out
Johnny's spreadsheet first of all is
just do this on the air the 31st of
December we're doing the pod right 10:30
in the morning the morning I think I'm
gonna come here and do it okay okay
deal then I guess I have to come here
and do it too it's set on the doing man
you were coming anyways awesome sorry we
just say no I'll do it I'll do that okay
you want to come in here yeah I think I
might have something I have to do here
eventually anyways I have my buddy Joe's
wedding so I forget if I had agreed to
that or not you said you were gonna come
here do it 10:30 to 11:30 and then okay
so here's the schedule for the next
couple weeks next week Tuesday week 15
recap comes out like normal Thursday we
are doing on Thursday morning the week
16 pics podcast will come out that day
so it's a little different than our
normal schedule
week 16 pics podcast comes out next
Thursday you better stay on me dude it
will be all over again and then on
Friday it will be a interview special
with Champ Bailey coming out so next
week Tuesday week 15 recap Thursday week
16 picks Friday Champ Bailey special
week of Christmas only two podcasts
coming out that week Tuesday the 25th
Christmas Day the week 16 recap is
coming out what a gift what a gift there
you go the two little elves here it's
gonna come wrapped Friday of Christmas
week I don't have the date down that
will be the week 17 picks podcast so
only two pot podcasts coming out that
week any questions so far now but that's
the 28th that Friday the perfect yeah if
you could have the calendar pulled up
that would be great so my brother's
birthday [ __ ] out two brothers whoa
shout out week of December 31st week of
New Year's Tuesday New Year's Day week
17 recap is coming out we are taping a
podcast on New Year's Eve maybe we'll do
it should we do it around like 11:00 at
night and then we can have the podcast
end with the
drop absolutely not perfect I will see
you guys here stoned and drunk on
tequila at that point perfect and then
uh so yeah New Year's week is gonna be a
normal week New Year's Day week 17 recap
comes out Thursday week 17 film pod
comes out and then Friday is our
wildcard weekend picks silly crap I will
tweet that in spreadsheet form if anyone
would like to print it out and put it up
on their walls so we gotta make sure
those we're gonna keep working even
during the holiday but that is the
schedule woah mother hen Johnny Google
document and I am done talking for
today's body no you're not first of all
are you washing these at any point are
Simpson left cold mugs or drinking water
I put a little water in them and I swirl
it around and then I fill them back up
you swirl so you're not getting the
outside of the mouthpieces now anything
like that now I would expected more out
of you yes you're not drinking water
doing this podcast it's doing dirty Cup
Josh all the other don't worry that's
happening today is there is a fly in the
studio I haven't seen an image and it's
aggressive it just tried to land in my
hot chocolate if anyone the podcast
kills the fly you get 30 seconds to talk
about whatever you want
there could be environment oh that could
be Google Docs right that's survivor
Rutgers basketball if I'm gonna kill
this fly if you kill the fly survivor
board gets 30 seconds okay one of the
best seasons of Survivor you didn't
build a fly okay okay I'm going mr.
miyagi style and getting this thing I
have my thing ready to go
Carson Wentz might be done for the year
yeah back spasms yeah someone DM me and
they asked do you think Carson's been
hurt for a while and I turned that
question to you my one friend said
whenever he's hurt his face turns red
and he's been red all season so I don't
know little Theory theory I would argue
that everything about Carson Wentz is
right exactly
I can't I don't see anything that no
jumps out to me to say and I'm trying to
think of is there a play he was dialing
them up it is now you know throwing is
very stressful on the lower back there's
a reason you've seen Tony Romo with back
problems then Roethlisberger's had them
Troy Aikman had him your quarterback at
Syracuse a few weeks ago yes played the
next week it is very stressful on that
lower back toward right so the torquing
you take a hit and get twisted the wrong
sometimes it can go out it's just like a
golfer with back back issues at times
that's why I always thought with Tony
Romo I thought it was the amount of golf
he played I'm sure there was a
basketball it was like exponentially
worse for his career I would I would
think it put a lot of pressure there I
am an Eagles fan that believes that the
Eagle season is already over right I
don't see a reason to play Carson Wentz
yeah but I will say that I have fear of
one thing yeah that Nick Foles goes into
LA and hangs up whole 150 yards and four
touchdowns and we go through an entire
offseason of foals versus wins yeah I
know I know I don't think we have to
have that fear I'm curious how much the
line dropped when Carson wins what was
the line there originally yeah but I
would think like the Rams are what a
point favorites am i weird that I don't
like to play the miracle game where like
I'm hearing Giants fans be like here are
the nine things that we need to have
happen for us to make the playoffs I
just don't really partake in it
yeah is that weird no I don't think it
is you know I don't think I'm like that
either until it starts to get really
close and narrowed down to one or two
things looks like one or two I'm not
gonna sit here and try to keep track of
like oh these nine amazing things have
to happen
we're like for the Browns right I look
at the AFC I got my seven teams that I'm
interested in for the six spots yes the
five teams that are there and either
Colts or Ravens like the six I'm with
NFC all of the vision winners that are
currently listed right Seahawks and then
we're either going Vikings or who I'd
rather see Carolina than the Vikings in
wow that's awful I know but at least the
Carolina I just go damn well [ __ ]
they're like Carolina and then you got
Philadelphia yeah yeah see I would
rather see at least Cam Newton and that
even though it's hurt Cam Newton yeah I
still would rather see it I would like
to since Vikings without offensive
coordinator T Filippo right I guess
there's just a part of me that I don't
want to see like Vikings bears first
round again that's what I have much as I
can take the under
are you so hot bombs so the Rams open is
eight and a half point favorites
twelve and a half they are as high as 12
and a half it's actually all over the
place nine ten and a half 11 12 and a
half
depending upon where you bet the line is
different I uh I know our betting show
us tomorrow
the Eagles played two games there's like
two games cuz that overtime pier and
their defense had 93 snaps I saw on your
sheet yeah and their secondary is a mess
and they don't generate pressure with
their front four and Nick Foles I'm
laying the wood oh I mean I mean they
might win bite when I'm not gonna lie I
was thinking about $100 but I mean I was
thinking about going thirteen sixty that
hard I could just go all it feels like
the Saints Eagles game that we saw it
like it feels like it's good right attic
and you're gonna get the Rams pissed off
back at home all of those ready to show
the world what they're really right yeah
so expect a lot of money on that
tomorrow
speaking of the Vikings night stinks
really do you think you would have bet
that money of course and once didn't get
hurt
yes okay yeah dude I'm so like I'm there
so done look I have got to pick the
Cowboys to win the division so you know
where his head's at yeah I just like to
be right yeah uh Monday Night Football
Viking Saints I want to start here
Vikings Seahawks excuse me yeah the
amount of slander directed at Kirk
Cousins during that game and after that
game needs to be addressed
yeah what were you thinking as you were
hearing yeah I mean it's just to me I
always go back to the word lazy okay
it's just a lazy take it's just to go
what's different from last year from
this year oh the quarterback it must be
him I mean it's just it's ridiculous I
go back to I think about Stefon Diggs
when we talked to him last time he goes
if you don't think her cousin's is
playing really good then I don't know
what you're watching I mean that comment
was not a political answer that was a
like no he's doing awesome
we have issues they are a to trick pony
and it was if you have one on one
let's throw two digs or Thielen sit and
that's it and what's happened in Seattle
that's good stuff it's all right Seattle
did stuff that we saw New England do a
little bit and I haven't watched us film
yet but just some of the replays we
talked about you were saying that you
were seeing the defense not doing the
cover three press bail Dublin feeling
and digs and so native concept proved
mean provement proved me you can throw
to somebody else and make it happen I
heard your Lombardi your
boy Lombardo your boy your guy Lombardi
talking about it saying that de Filippo
attacks schemes right he was coming up
with his cover three press bail beaters
instead of calling an offense yeah right
yeah yeah III think that but everyone
likes to throw Kirk Cousins 84 million
dollars in his face oh it's all it's
about it's all I ever hear about is the
the money and he's got to carry the team
all by himself I mean damn so but woodsy
so this is where I have no problem with
people being critical of Kirk Cousins
but Mike were too it would be then if
we're going to be critical of him then
where is the criticism of Matt Ryan he's
making more money and this team's doing
worse where where is it I don't
understand see that's where I just don't
get football we couldn't we just find
guys and we go he's looking fun to
criticize is it because the Vikings are
in the playoff race and the Falcons are
not I guess so I'm not hearing any
criticism about Matt Stafford right now
you know what I mean you're right and I
think it's just because when you're not
in the race right nobody really got yes
you're right there's probably really
part of it no no I think that's probably
a big part of it I think you're right
there we did have a question on YouTube
for Muhammad her say with John D Filippo
getting fired what can Stefanski do to
improve the Vikings no I I mean I think
really the the reason it has changed
more than anything is just the run game
I think that's the biggest thing
I mean Zimmer is a Bill Parcells
disciple he's a defensive coach those
two things in itself lead it to run the
football you know I think of like you
know whoever it was Jim Schwartz a few
weeks ago when they played the when they
played the Saints he goes when I look at
Sean's offense is awesome but I also I
can imagine Bill Parcells in his ear
going run the ball here Sean you write
down like for the Cowboys you wrote down
three different running games right one
thing that I'm not able to do when I
watch games yeah is to identify run
scheme I just I don't have that ability
yeah I I can't tell if a team runs the
same thing all the time I can't see that
yet yeah I'm not adept at pulling up
pulling guards and all that yeah
the Vikings run offense I'm hearing from
a lot of people it just wasn't
imaginative at all no because when the
media talks about it they look at
carries
right and they look at run versus pass
play calls yes but like the runs that
they did do were they creative were they
good was a good scheme no not at all
it's basic stuff it's the same two or
three schemes all the time it's either
inside zone or it's uh let's do the
Philadelphia Eagles Chip Kelly pull
everybody it's almost like an outside
zone but there's pulling guards that go
along with it
it was one or two of those things and
Shermer on the other hand is more like a
he's a true man-to-man
for the most part type a blocker he
wants to pull guards he wants to trap
defensive tackles he wants to do things
like that and it's more of a Smash Mouth
downhill running style of course he has
the zone scheme involved there
everybody's got both but I think that's
where they really lacked let alone
forget the schemes just the lack of
patience with it and Tamia always goes
back to the new thing of it's the
quarterback whisperer thing everybody
thinks they're going to get their next
head coaching job as long as the
quarterback numbers look good I I'm
gonna say this right now I think with
Stefanski it's not gonna be as big as a
jump like Freddie kitchens but I think
when you have a guy that was in house
for a few years and was being groomed
yeah not forget Zimmer blocked from
Stefanski from joining Shermer in New
York with the giant right I believe that
it's gonna bring some consistency back
to that offense they could have won that
game easily Seahawks Seahawks crap the
Bell the opportunity what did you think
about the Seahawks offense t-bar 31 on
youtube says can you guys please talk
about Rashad Penny getting better every
game yeah talk about him but also like I
didn't that was a great Seahawks
offensive performance I mean the
interception from Russell loan yeah yeah
no it was a bad interception again I'll
remind everybody to if we had David
Moore drag his feet properly and would
have been a touchdown there that would
have never happened good foot hey that
was a you know I still like the Seahawks
offense especially what they do in the
run game
I think we're shot penny is going to be
special and every time he touches it
like it looks pretty damn good right and
I don't think he's totally healthy after
what we saw from that Packers whatever
it was foot ankle injury either way
the passing game is never going to blow
you away in Seattle they kind of want to
just run the ball their philosophy is
run the ball control the clock defense a
coach and Pete Carroll right and then
they want to just go okay now we got
some one-on-ones and we got Lockett and
we got David Moore and a few of these
other guys all that's been hurt and
bobbles it hurt but either way then
they're just gonna go alright we'll do
some play actions and some shots off of
that when we have some man-to-man shots
because Russell is a great deep ball
thrower and that's it but I don't ever
watch the Seahawks often to go like oh
wow these pass game schemes are
unbelievable right it's really about
their run game and they just want to
take a few shots and they usually
capitalize on it so something really big
happened this week Sims yeah really big
really and I don't even think you saw it
and it's rare right so over this
offseason mm-hmm Ben Baskin of Sports
Illustrated wrote an article it was an
article that included the quote my arm
strength is probably too strong The
Ballad of Davis Webb yes well just today
the New York Daily News Manish Mehta
wrote an article about Davis Webb oh my
gosh he's back I've read it and I've
boiled it down to a few things yeah
first what we've learned the Jets third
string quarterback rises at 5:02
everyday he's literally the first player
in the building he eats early bird
dinners he leaves the team facility at
8:00 and he goes to bed by 9:00 I will
say all of the quotes from the Jets were
very glowing it's good darn old said
he's a super hard worker awesome to have
around when he doesn't have a lot of
energy Davis brings it out in him
Jermaine Kearse said he watches a lot of
film and they emphasize like he said it
like that right right and mechag ninh
says he's been outstanding off the field
shows talent interested in his
development hmm the big reason it was a
thing is he said I want to start in this
league yeah out of all due respect he
goes Sam he deserves it he's the best
quarterback on this team yeah he
deserves it but in the end I want to
start Jets are trying to groom him to be
the backup right
he's gonna be an exclusive rights free
agent after this season right the fact
that he's back is insane it is and I'm
just curious are you upset that an
article was even written about him again
yeah I think it's a little weird
I do I mean it's just that to me it's
again it's a third-string quarterback
and we're gonna focus on that this time
of the year I mean again he is an
intriguing prospect we know that I mean
he does have sighs he's got decent
athleticism and there's the flies um get
it left go I am get it move fly don't
fly I could I didn't want to splash now
I can't drink but he's an intriguing he
is an intriguing prospect I understand
that I mean there are some starting
caliber traits there but yes this point
of the year to be doing this and again
know the first thing I think of here in
this situation is ok diminish meta
approach the Jets about this because I
have a hard time believing that I have a
hard time management was like well let
me look at this there's all these things
going with a team well he said that he
goes look this is a guy that might be
the future maybe in that three week span
the future for who well no he's saying
maybe in that span in which Sam Darnell
was hurt maybe instead of playing Josh
McCown you played this guy yeah whatever
I agree with you why did that you so eat
so it's all yours he theory so my
conspiracy theory is so did he reach out
to the Jets or is Davis Webb's
agent setting these things up ago she
agent I don't know I'm just saying hey
Manish you know can you do a little
things I mean that's how that crap works
and it's just such a political writer I
talked to some people the Jets right
really do love Davis way yeah that's
cool but also at the same time I think
what was the thing I was going to say
there I can't remember it's just odd
either way there was a cop what was the
comment I was making before you said
what was your conspiracy theory there
what was I about to say I can't remember
either way well do you know you know why
they didn't pay him cuz I sold a chance
no cuz oh oh let's let's play him so he
can do awesome and then we can talk
about this and this is we have a thing
in the off season if Sam Darla starts
off slow next year we go
who Davis Webb
good in those three meaningless games
that's why he's the guy yes exactly
right you like the Avengers right I do
okay
love the Avengers when a new Avengers is
released there's two stages
there's the press release and then
there's the movie trailer this article
is the press release for an upcoming
movie Nick if I can get some music is
this a new one are we still talking
about Davis Webb here if you could have
one second please please sit back the
movies are going alright let's see if I
can do this without coughing and dying
after a season of silence deep in a cave
now glossed in green a tale turns at
5:02 am the only eyes in the building
focused on film binders clutched in its
claws a man facing insurmountable odds a
quarterback ready to seize his rightful
throne as the king of New York coming in
off season 2019 Davis Webb returns in
return of the Dragon this time he's an
exclusive rights free agent Davis Webb
2019 you excited for it are you gonna be
ready for this no dude I love how
excited Josh and I got when we saw this
article because it I think it's
hilarious and I love how much it upsets
you right it's just weird I don't think
it's a good look for him I really don't
you find out who his agent was he's with
Wasserman but I don't know who him you
got to figure out who represents Manish
Mehta if you want to play the long game
yeah right I mean yeah cuz I do know my
agent represents some people yeah and I
nothing's ever happened like that yeah
no no it would be it'd be interesting
that would be a great conspiracy theory
if the agent reached out to him I just
saw that today I just heard or it were
it just managed just man he is so
connected with the Jets he's some of
that too where yeah they could have told
them something like that already who
knows all right so let's go to the film
notebook
Reyes there's a week 15 here and we just
spent 10 of the first 30 minutes of our
podcast on Davis Webb I don't love it
let's go
I love very on-brand for Simms atomic
roosters on YouTube said fan geoscheme
versus McVeigh Joyce 8 or gaming said
I'd love to hear about Rams Bears so
let's get right into it
I've gone through the notes good I'm
gonna point out the ones that are
interesting and then kind of go into it
yeah you you wrote the great thing about
Fangio's linebackers and safeties first
thing can we just start here just that
you forgot that they start on the 15 and
only got three
exactly and that they also got three on
the fake punt Drive I just which made
the Bears performance even better
exactly and I just really I didn't mean
to cut you off but I just wanted to like
I didn't see the beginning of the game I
want to emphasize how hard that is and
how you have to be truly special to go
hmm we're sitting on the sidelines we're
watching our team right we're just
sitting there okay we're gonna have to
get ready here in a minute
offense is going there on a drive kind
of moving the ball okay we're on the hot
seat there and kind of getting warmed up
hey we're moving the ball here this be
cool yeah
David's up okay Oh theythey intercepted
it okay let me get my helmet on take my
coat off okay we got to get out there
holy [ __ ] it's the best offensive
football they're at the 15-yard line and
we got to get on our [ __ ] like right now
we can't have like a one play like let's
get used to [ __ ] thing this is like we
got to stop them now or this game could
be big trouble right away yeah I mean
that in football world in my eyes is
that's tough so you would say when
there's an early turnover and the
defense has to go on the field more
often than not they're gonna score I
would say so yes that's a special
defense that could handle that situation
and still keep their mental wits about
them
yes and understand what they're trying
to accomplish as a whole instead of just
being flustered with everything so
that's all right that's where I just
wanted to just give some props to that
the number one thing that kept popping
up in your notes yeah is how the Bears
d-line whooped ass yes there were 72
seemingly mentions of some different
types of ass whoopings you said the
Bears d-line is the Rams kryptonite you
said Leonard Freud deserves a lot more
credit you said that Khalil Mack is so
good with 500s
that the Bears actually did not have to
blitz until the third quarter and we're
still able to do it you went down the
line of the Rams off and so when none of
these guys have a good matchup with this
bears deal I know none of them it was
that big of an ass well it was that big
of an ass well but had you seen a team
do this to the Rams no nobody's done
this to the Rams often Saints T lines
pretty good yeah it is but it's not on
the level of this D line this D lines I
mean they're special D line
you know I think the first thing you
talk about of course we know Mac Donald
whoever those two of the two best
defensive players of football I mean Mac
is that good and he gave Whitworth and
Havenstein all they can handle
I mean they were outmatched there and
that's not saying much I mean Khalil Mac
is gonna out match just about anybody
for the most part so that okay but what
gets in trouble is you know what they do
a lot of the times to left go is they
try to slide the line towards Mac right
so then Whitworth of course can go I'm
gonna set outside really hard because my
guards sliding over here too and he can
kind of play the inside move but what
happens with that is then because of
that either the guard or center arm and
up with Hakeem Hicks and if there is a
kryptonite with the Rams offense it is
the two guys in the middle 60 guards the
center in the girl oh one of the guards
is is totally fine Sapp olds fine oh
Saffold apiece but the other of those
humans that you go that's as absurd
looking human yeah I mean he's athletic
he can do it all he's really great or
two at Sullivan and Blythe they were
issues and they got whooped continually
through the football game whether it was
Goldman or Hicks
good night mater yes they are both great
and then you get the Roy Robertson
Harris in there you start to cycle
through but yes that's the first thing
they do to you because you go okay we
got a slide to help out just a little
I'm Khaleel Mack but they're so good
it's really hard for most offensive
lines to feel good about the rest of the
matchups on euro line yeah so you said
the match it will be tough whether this
is an LA or Chicago this is the defense
that matches up with them it's the
defense that matches up with them yes
because because it doesn't matter about
the past catchers it doesn't matter
about the athletes if you can't block
those monsters up front right nothing
matters nothing matters and as we always
say with Fangio which I always love and
you've heard me say this for three years
now
he errors on stopping the pass he
doesn't go I'm gonna bring my safety
right up to the line of scrimmage
to stop a run and make it two yards he
goes I got a [ __ ] awesome defensive
front they're gonna stop it I'm there
you know if they get five okay that they
start to do it consistently then maybe
I'll do it but he
they were never worried about the
play-action all night they just said our
guys will do it to him we're not worried
about ro Quan Smith and everybody having
to fly up in there and stop it we
believe our guys can control that part
of it you did write this yeah gothis
playing scared yeah and has bad
mechanics yes
golf's motion was weird during the game
he got into this real
so golf is what I would call a handy
thrower you got a football behind it oh
yeah I didn't know what you meant by
that you kept saying too much hand too
much hand like you know you see you see
a Rogers right Rogers Rogers stays here
Brady stays here golf can get his arm
like really wide open like this and he
tries to just do it with his wrist
almost through it right instead of
making it one ball one thing this
shouldn't really break until like the
very end and they keep tight arm angles
like really good throwers even Patrick
mahomes is flexible it is it very rarely
loses this 90 they don't get it away
from your body
yeah right well in Bothell let it get
too far out here you lose the
centrifugal force exactly right yeah it
becomes almost a little bit of an
independent contractor yeah and if
you're not on that day and just don't
have it going and okay now it's it's a
little cold and the ball slick and you
don't have a going and you're a hand
thrower like that the ball wobbles a
little when the Chicago win it'll
explode on you so this has been
happening for a while this is not just
this game this is what he does a little
bit if there was a flaw with him as a
thrower this is what he does but we saw
it come to the top because it was a cold
weather game and he was a little
uncomfortable and he just wasn't on his
game but his motion got very
over-the-top at times too like more than
normal where I was going man what was
going on here he threw some screwballs
in the game I don't know any other way
to say it where I just go whoa that's
spin on that ball and it dove into the
ground like nobody's gonna be able to
catch that but he was he had people he
was scared I don't know if he was all I
know but I just he was seeing some
ghosts that time moving like out of the
pocket like I told you with the
interception when they were backed up on
their own end zone yeah you know he
moved into his left tackle he didn't
really
have to if he just stood there and
through it he was going to be fine
but he had had people around him and he
wasn't comfortable and he just wanted to
move to get extra space but he backed up
into his left tackle who's trying to
block lil Mac and then he hits him and
the ball doesn't go anywhere so when but
his decision-making wasn't like even
confident either where I've seen him
come out and just come out firing
he was second-guessing himself and
patent the ball and yeah it just wasn't
one of his fine performances so when
McVeigh watches all of the stuff that
you just talked about on film yeah
is this all correctable for an NFC
playoff game or is this stuff where it's
just I'm limited by my personnel and you
know it's it's it's correctable hey this
game could have been closer they dropped
a few balls
I wouldn't depend on golf throwing for
dumb interceptions like he did the next
time you play around but the next time
they play McVeigh will have the
advantage to a degree
cuz he's gonna go okay I can't do the
same game plan I have to do something
remarkably different this time around
to change how they attacked us and he
will come up with something through that
and yes I mean I would expect Jared Goff
this again it's a learning experience
this is a young football team it's
really the first time they've ever been
in this type of environment on the road
cold game Sunday Night Football
primetime primetime right so this was it
is again like I said I mean Girly's in
his third year god I mean fourth year
Girly's I mean golf's in his third year
I mean it's just they're still learning
how to be battle tested and managed
football games like this you did right
on the other side the Bears are a tough
matchup for the Rams d they spread you
out and the Rams don't have enough big
people to stop them in their sets yes
you said that true risky's interceptions
were bad yes one was a floater one was a
bad decision right one was a bad throw
right and you wrote with an exclamation
point that he's stepping in the bucket
bucket right so so um okay firm for any
quarterback out there and we're talking
about a righty okay so if you're a
righty quarterback out there and you
want to throw the ball to 12 o'clock
just imagine you're standing in the
middle of a clock is your left foot go
to 12 o'clock it should go slightly to
the left
thirty I should go to 1130 exactly right
so then your upper body can rotate
through and you're not blocked off by
your lower body ringing like wait I
can't even twist through it my let my
legs at 12:00 and I can't get all the
way through so you want to be slightly
open so let me guess was his foot at
9:00 exactly that guy's the blanket
that's the bucket he's almost not he's
not stepping to the target he's almost
stepping backwards or sideways right
it's not a let me throw it there and get
my momentum going there let me throw it
there and my mentum is going here
psychologically why would a person do
that I would think are they trying to
avoid the rush are they trying to guide
it more I think it's a more of a guide
to your opening yourself up a little bit
yes arch exactly a little bit and he's
normally not like that that's why I'm
like I'm not terribly concerned with his
performance I think some of the throws
he missed he will hit they were some
dumb dumb decisions - I know he was
sitting on the wall behind you like the
whole time he loved your your chocolate
just ran them right in there push them
and I'd say see he's in there I think
should I just shake it I don't want to
ruin the mousepad
oh no not the mousepad work can afford
go for a bath in the hot chocolate that
means that josh is gonna get to do
survivor talk great move by you stay
tuned everybody we're talking survivor
yeah we don't know what's in there but
we have a guess it's probably in there
all right so key code yeah so he they
weren't terribly concerned about your
Biscay I'm not terribly concerned about
it I thought people are i he saw the
field well that's what another thing is
hilarious right we are more concerned
about the guy who threw three
interceptions of the game than the guy
who threw four that's the first thing I
noticed Monday morning we're everybody
was more talking about true bisque 'is
bad play than they were about Jared Goff
which was mind blown because golf was
the envy in the MVP conversation like
four weeks ago yes but now he just gets
a free pass for throwing four
interceptions on the road with the best
offensive football or second best and I
just want to give a shout out listener
Sean McVeigh for listening to Sims and
going simpler on defense thank you
they definitely did way to go Sean you
listen to this in your test but yes I
think so
you wrote you I thought his best line
rice about being simple was Richard
Sherman got paid a lot of money playing
zone right it's a good line thank you
you don't get up you don't got to be
doing press man you don't gotta be go up
in the face Richard Sherman made a lot
of money playing exactly right drop
Peters backdrop to lead back exactly
those guys get up there get pressure I
liked their defense approach in this
game better than any game I've seen the
whole year that's good go for it is good
going forward you know they don't need
to do crazy crazy stuff on defense they
got crazy crazy pyres as is right so for
them to have aggressive players along
with an aggressive scream it's like two
negatives equal pot it's like those two
together
that's dangerous Aaron Donald is gonna
go through the gap he wants to sometimes
no matter what cuz you just gonna go I
got this guy set up I'm going inside
here cuz he's been playing me outside
and I'm gonna go and see if I can make a
play Marcus Peters is going to go for a
pick six eventually you don't know what
to call them you don't need to call the
defense to go I'm gonna try to set him
up for the pits pick six cuz what
happens in those cases then it goes
going Oh 70 yards right down the middle
nobody's there because we were going for
the jugular instead of just playing
defense so I like that approach but back
to the main point to it was like the
Bears offense is a tough matchup for the
Rams Dee you know just like the next
time around I say the Bears Dee's not
gonna be able to rely on you know golf
playing that bad and McVeigh I'll have
some new tricks well it'd be the same
thing for the Bears - and the Bears play
the Rams the next time around you know
true but I wouldn't count on true Biscay
missing the some of those throws right
and also Nagy's didn't have a better
feel for some of the things they did
that he didn't expect them to do as a
whole to play them but the Bears are
tough to defend for a team like the Rams
who they want to win with their speed
and chaos but the Bears you have to
respect their spread sets because they
have speed out there yes and then they
have an offensive line that's a nice
blend of not overly big people but big
people who are pretty athletic too so
and negates some of what the Rams are so
good at and it fells all about match it
is all about matchups speaking of
matchups this is not one that you've
watched on film but I have two questions
yeah Steelers Raiders right we're gonna
go there now okay
are you buying Big Ben's excuse know
about old medical equipment and well
yeah there's no there's I'm sure there
was all medical
what what did he have to see so the
story was what that there was an old
x-ray machine that took a while to what
warm-up and he said he was waiting for
the technician and then it took him a
while you don't believe that well no I
believe that I buy that it's the Oakland
Coliseum
it is a [ __ ] it was an amazing left
go PR move so because what you do is you
find the one thing that everyone's gonna
go oh yeah Oakland what a shitbox and
then you're scot-free it was a beautiful
move because they might have the most
up-to-date x-ray machine ever but if you
said they got a crappy x-ray machine I'm
believing it a thousand it's a good one
and yes but but my point is why did it
matter like you played at the end of the
half you felt okay yeah I'm sure you
weren't perfect so that that's all my
point is I point this is the captain
your point is it's not about procedure
it's about pain tolerance yeah and if
you were able to play at the end it
doesn't matter if it came back as
positive or negative or sitting there on
the sidelines and you're not like in a
miserable pain and everything's going
like well you needed the doctor to like
what if it was cracked you're red were
you just gonna go all I'm not gonna play
or are you gonna go let me see if I
could throw it and try to make it happen
here I mean plenty of quarterbacks have
played with cracked ribs before yeah but
what kind of injuries have you played
through have a question for you I was
thinking I thought this after the Denver
game yeah I felt more so after the
Raiders game right convince me that
Antonio Brown is a better wide receiver
than juju yeah I know it's a tough one
he's most versatile I'll give them that
because I'm at a point now yeah well I
think juju might be a better wide
receiver than Antonio Brown I think he's
faster I think he's a bigger Gator right
yeah I believe that he can get open on
more different types of quarterbacks I I
don't disagree with that either
I juju is the better outside receiver
I'll say that right off the bat Antonio
Brown is undoubtedly a better slot
receiver than juju and the you know but
I like juju better on krauser he's
because he's fearless and he can use his
size you're right I mean only that it I
have seen juju takes so many balls 45
yards and go right haven't really seen a
Antonio Brown do it once this you know I
I know these are things that
you know you know again I think if we
went back in time and when he just
didn't have a straight shot of catching
a ball with nobody around him I think it
would be harder to find some of those
plays than Antonio Brown then people
realize like where oh he caught a slant
and broke a tackle and then outran a
bunch of people down the sideline and
broke somebody's that you know angle
that they had for a long touchdown you
know he he I think I said it last week
maybe it was the week before they need
to put him in the slot more that's where
Antonio Browns the best I believe that
was last week but maybe it was the week
before because I think that's a part of
their offense they're missing like we
were talking about having to find that
third receiver right and I think they
are at their best when they use Antonio
inside more and then you keep juju
outside for whatever it may be and the
sparing deep cross or a shallow cross
and things like that but as an outside
receiver left goal I am with you juju is
special he's special he really is he's
unbelievable and adjusting to the ball
I'll take juju over Thielen I would to
having take juju I had eggs I would - I
would take juju over Davante Adams I
would take juju
I would think juju is the six or seventh
best wide receiver the NFL I know when
we did the work I think I had him at
eight at the time maybe someone there I
think I had feeling maybe one spot ahead
of him I mean exactly juju it's every
week and again like you and I have seen
him before juju for all those that are
out there James is a big dude he don't
be fooled by that number 19 like this
guy was like a strong saftey going into
college that's what they see right so
you know he's an upper echelon no doubt
about that yes I just but it's a good
conversation I think it's worth throwing
out there to the fans at this point I
mean it really is I mean again you know
I got a lot of flack for him putting him
in the top ten over people like Mike I'm
at nine nine okay for putting him in
front of people like Michael Thomas and
things like that you know what's funny
about football
I mean Juju's forth and football and
receiving yards right now yeah you know
Adam feelin's third now Tyree kills
number two with yards now okay he is
climbed up the ladder and Julio's the
only one beat him but this is where I
just like to talk about the quarter the
wide receiver thing that's so
amazing about what Tyreke Hill is doing
out of the people that are leading
football and yardage there's only two
guys that have like the yards per catch
like Tyree killed us they're on another
level of what they're doing Tyree killed
and Mike Evans are the only two guys
that are up there at the 17 yards per
reception category out of the guys that
are League leaders and yardage
department that's to me that's a special
thing I mean that to me it means to me
but when you're getting the ball you're
striking whether that's slants you're
breaking a tackle on or your absolute
vertical down the field speed is such a
weapon that it's backing defenses off
and when you run craw deep crossers
you're in cuts it's 20 yard gain so I
just think those are they're interesting
little nuggets the number one receiver
in the NFL at 20-plus yard receptions is
Tyree kill the number one receiver at
40-plus yard receptions as Tyree kill
mmm Antonio Brown is second at 40 plus
yards and I feel like a lot of them were
deep bombs it's it's just a different
type of Antonio's gonna catch it when
it's 45 yards in the air Reiter
JooJoo for me is a guy that's gonna take
it ten and then take it 40 yes I would
totally agree with that okay let's keep
going yes Eagles Cowboys this is from a
reddit user Sammy solo papa cigar Amari
Cooper thought which I love that he's
thinking about Amari Cooper and he's
wondering if when Amari went from a
top-class
facility in Alabama and from everything
he's heard the absolute garbage
facilities in Oakland could that have
messed with him and now he's in Dallas
where it's right back to the Alabama
standard of a really quality facility
and then he asked is he too baked is he
too baked the guy asking the question
said is that true I lied to bake no no I
think that's a I think it's a you're
having a good strand right now that
sounds like it's not it's not it's not
going to like change him as a player I
think it's a good thought I mean that's
a good back porch daddy cigar thought
because there is it is true like NFL
players get to me
I'll give you as kasenyi number one
access to Texas and I was like I mean we
were the best facility in football and I
got drafted by the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
and I drove up and I was like damn
trailers are we got trailers connected
to our facility where the [ __ ] am I
am i back at high school wait my high
school locker room was better than this
hold on what am i back in peewee
football we were at Oakland's training
camp right it was at high school there
in a high school gym I know so it can be
underwhelming for some of these big
school stars when they come to the pros
and they go damn like this is I'm it's
way less cutting edge of a facility as
compared to where I was in college it's
finally getting there in the NFL teams
that finally realized that it increases
their team worth when they have these
big facilities right there for free so
they're exactly so they're starting to
build all these things in Dallas like
showing up in Austin if you're a high
school recruit like you get to Dallas
and you just can't believe what the
Cowboys have yes it's like Dallas would
be I would say in that upper echelon of
like professional organizations in the
NF study them and the Mavericks both in
Dallas are like the upper level of
treating players like professional
athletes right right I mean they have
their football facility is the Ford
Center right and they have a $25,000
stadium it's connected to their football
facility so yeah you 25,000 25,000 see
sorry like they'll my big - that's a
really cheap great deal Jerry knows how
to do it but yeah I mean Dallas is a
special organization I I'll say this
like there's some organizations that are
like I always look at some of the
original organizations I know that I
constantly am told by coaches who go
maybe their first time to the Giants or
the Steelers I'll even throw the Ravens
or the Patriots or let me just see who
else I'm missing here all the teams yep
I'm just thinking of anybody else
I mean the the Bears being one the
Dallas Cowboys being another where I
would say are in these lists of yes
through these old teams where coaches
get there and they go man this is what
professional football is all about like
it's just it's a little bit of a
different atmosphere it's more
professional on a daily basis
the owners walking around the building
you know it's just like oh okay I'm not
you know I don't want to do my main
question be what's the difference what's
like like what's happening in Tampa
that's not happening in New York they're
not you know New York is not having
meetings at the Hooters to go over their
players who's gonna get cut during
tradition they've been doing it for 15 I
mean they are well schooled these are
like football businesses it's not just
like some hotshot owner came in and
threw a billion dollars out and just
said we're gonna wheel and deal and play
and hey you guys going to Hooters and
drink some beers and figure out who
makes the team remember they did that in
Hard Knocks like the Giants aren't doing
that like member do you remember that
the Bucks to the Bucs and hard knocks
they had one of their Jason like Jason
Lite had one of their meetings at
Hooters I can promise you that the
Giants are the Pittsburgh staff just a
branded con are not gonna not going
there but I don't even know what my
point of this whole no I think it's
interesting yeah yeah all right into the
film Cowboys offense Eagles defense
you're away the top 93 plays which
showed you how much the Eagles were on
the field
you said the Cowboys run game had good
diversity you said honestly with the
Eagles Bennett and Cox Michael Bennett
and Fletcher Cox are the only two Eagles
consistently balling Brandon Graham
Chris long have been very underwhelming
you wrote not just this game but all
season long yes Amari Cooper you wrote
one of the best route runners in the NFL
yeah he's I mean you know from our first
day ever seeing him in person he can
stop on a dime right I mean and we saw
how quick he got off the line of
scrimmage a few times I could still
remember you and me stand-in there in
Oakland the first time I was like this
and I was like whoa like that was
unbelievable I why did you say yes right
but it's he has special fast-twitch and
he's a creative route runner who likes
to I don't wanna say ad-lib a little bit
he comes off the line of scrimmage and
he hops and he skips yeah and then he
runs real hard like he's gonna run the
go route and then he jams his foot in
the ground and runs a slant route like
he really is great at changing speeds
changing the way he leans his body and
then giving a real nice noticeable some
thing body language wise ago here I come
quarterback I'm about to make my final
presence he really does he presents
themselves in a great way and they don't
do a lot with him because they don't
have to it's go rout its slant route
it's post corner which is like a a
deeper slant where then he puts the
brakes on it goes back outside that's
all they're doing but when you volunteer
yeah yeah right
you wrote dak fumble I've never seen a
guy get stripped sacked from the front
before right I mean he gets more that's
I think I've never seen it happening
like and I think I believe it happened
to him in the Tennessee Titans game when
he found blood there's like he has no
it's a good thing because it shows you
he's not watching the rush at all he's
fearless like he's just like but he's
got to have a little bit of more
awareness where I know this has got to
be at least a third or fourth strip sack
of the year where it's come right in
front of him to his face and he has no
idea it's like he's getting blindsided
but it's front sided and he still has no
idea it's coming Wow and that just like
especially in the moment that that game
the kind of game that was it was so
close yes like you have to be special
careful I wouldn't be mad at you if you
were flinching a little bit in the
pocket and that kind of games because
it's so close it's one play can change
it you did say that he played well and
that he at least put it at where he won
exactly right what does that mean I mean
I didn't see too many throws the
interception over the middle was wide
open threw it high
I'm trying oh the other interception he
threw it good he didn't see the backside
corner he has to know they ran basically
if everybody's listening out there three
receivers to the left right okay and
they're all running go routes so you got
three receivers to your left
but that inside receiver runs like it's
like a go route that he crosses the
field right he's gonna run to the
opposite pylon in the endzone and it's
great if you have man-to-man and you
know your backside corner is going with
the out route of the receiver over to
the right side or whatever dropped but
this was zone and he had nothing to
worry about on that side of the field
you have to know that he threw the
perfect ball but he didn't see the guy
so that was a bad
seeing the field right the other one was
the bad throw on the interception but
for the most part of the day I thought
the ball came out of his hand very clean
and he put it in the spot he was aiming
for I will say though that reading your
notes it's hard to evaluate them because
of the lack of pass rush from the Eagles
and their secondary exactly right I mean
your secondary is a disaster
Eagles offense Cobb why is boughs be
playing bump man-to-man and the biggest
moments of the game again sorry Cooper
the hottest receiver in football those
are the things to me where I just go I
don't get it like why doesn't anybody
like a brain fart
or why doesn't anybody in the sideline
just go let him run a slant and make the
tackle let them run the out and make the
tackle but don't get beat running on him
run straight by you because all of a
sudden you think you're Aqib Talib or
you know Marcus Peters who's gonna jam
them at the line of scrimmage and maybe
like lock down that I just don't
understand that Cowboys do have some
corners that can get on an island with
people yes but I thought the most
interesting thing is that halfway
through the notes of the Eagles offense
Sims switches to a fresh pen did you run
an ink boy boy that ink was populist
right it wasn't a great pen man yeah one
of my pens just isn't it's not happen
yeah I know I don't know why it's not
flowing good yeah but half way through
man it was dark it was a lie rich thank
you I need to make a staples runner no I
still I'm good yeah I'm good
Eagles offens you said no one on the
offense is special with the ball running
backs or receivers you said the Eagles
offense has no rhyme or reason and they
repeat calls all the time yeah so I mean
it's pretty fair to say that it's not
Dee Filippo it's not Doug Peterson it's
not grow it's Frank Reich yeah he took
that whole third down package up to Indy
huh no doubt he did how do they not just
keep some of the plays I don't know I
don't know if it's a lack of knowledge
or if it's a just know lack of the
creativity as far as what Reich brought
to the table and nobody can replace that
yeah you know what I haven't seen in a
while and a montage of Reich's comeback
I felt like when Reich like Reich all
the time they'd be like and they're down
14 points you know who else was down by
a lot of points Frank Reich his
quarterback of the Buffalo Bills when
they were taking on who were they
playing again they were playing the
Houston Oilers he did in Maryland - he
had a crazy comeback at Maryland
I just I haven't seen that video package
so if the Colts are down like 14 will
see it this week right but the big thing
that called my attention your notes yes
was Byron Jones yeah Cowboys matched
Byron Jones on Zach Ertz on third down
yeah and Sims nicknamed him the Earth's
eraser Diwali the Earth's erasing music
stopper I use an eraser right I mean
like his rookie year yeah you said that
Byron Jones was a Gronk stopper yeah now
he's the Earth's eraser right and you
went as far to say that him in a cheeto
be a loser yay or the second best
cornerback duo in the NFL I think so
I just you know like let's talk about it
right here I mean you know okay I'm
putting Jacksonville guys in front of
them figured Bowie and Ramsey but after
that you know looks like seriously it's
just a leave in Peters right and I don't
think they're on the level of these two
this year and especially Tilley missed
six or seven games so endo Scandrick and
Kendall think you're funny
I mean you got Minnesota Houston Texans
yeah I don't know if I can give him the
duo aspect of it though yes that's where
it falls to that but I guess I guess the
real thing is I weakened you in the
duo's but Byron Jones at this point yeah
if he's like like which what's your
statement on him well he was he was
played out of position in his first few
years right they move him to safety he
played college corner
they had Morris Claiborne they're like
they had some guy trying to get their
best 11 on this and by that they had to
pay him out of position I think this is
the position he's most comfortable at
the modern-day NFL he finally gets some
coaching from a Chris Rashard I was
always had an issue with Dallas's
defense is good but what they do in the
back end is not always sound and they
get gashed in the past game too much
that's what Chris Rashard has brought to
the table for the Cowboys not only
technique help for the DBS but they're
just more sound with their coverages
against different schemes than they were
in years past but their ability to match
and plays man in big situations it's
just it's such a big thing for that
because they don't have to blitz like
the Bears they can go for four for four
okay it's time for a curveball here
right let's throw six out of them and
we're gonna lock
man-to-man everywhere you wrote they had
no fear and they had no fear of your
guys cuz they knew that none of them can
really run by you I get it yeah all
right yeah all oryx's caches came on 1st
and 2nd down zone coverage with not
Byron Jones on him alright
Chiefs offense Ravens defense yeah what
match up so many notes I wrote down it's
crazy first off you wrote Ravens might
have the best offensive scheme the
league but they don't have the guys the
Bears and Cowboys have to get after the
quarterback yes so you think you wrote
so many times wink exposed the Kansas
City pass schemes he knew where they
would slide like their past block
passing you wrote Wow Ravens disguising
well bringing the Blitz more than I saw
on TV yeah you wrote so many times I
can't get over how many chances the
Ravens D took with all these blitzes yes
so you believe right now that Martindale
of the Ravens as a defensive coordinator
yeah has the best scheme in the NFL I do
I think so yes on a weekly basis
his ability just game plan specific
their soundness and everything they do
they can bring creative blitzes and
still be exactly in the right gaps if
like a run play happens and you don't
believe they're the most talented
defense I don't think they're the most
talented defense no I think they I would
give the Cowboys and the Bears the best
defensive title and I'd probably go
bears one Cowboys to because their front
fours can get home by themselves always
wink Martindale the challenge he has to
deal with is they're big on the
defensive front but they don't have
great pass rushers
as we saw on the Patrick mahomes fourth
and nine exactly right they have to
create things to happen at times and
which makes you typically vulnerable
which makes you typically vulnerable so
you either have to be really good at
zone blitzing and then knowing oh
they're in this formation I know where
I'm gonna drop because in this formation
they like to run these concepts okay
great or you have to go ok damn we're
gonna have to play man-to-man and even
when you have to play man-to-man there
has to be some sort of understanding
especially as well as they covered in
some of those situations to go your
defensive coach told you okay we're in
man-to-man but they like to run these
routes and this here so there
deform it's not like they're just like
okay I've never seen this before I'm
just man to man and I don't know what's
gonna happen
there have things in their mind where
they're going oh wait okay its third and
eight wink said all week that when we do
this and there's two receivers out here
to the side that these are the three
combinations I got to be ready for I'm
you know what I mean so if you start
looking for clues exactly right and then
that's where they are really great the
Baltimore Ravens defense with that being
said I'm just kind of looking ahead to
Thursday night yeah the Chargers have
the corners and the secondary guys to
match up they do yes not really match up
attack I know it's hard to match up I
don't know their corners aren't as good
as the Ravens really no I don't think so
okay when you go when you go car Jimmy
Smith and Humphrey it's a pretty good
cover that's what we're hearing were you
more wrong about Leighton van Dhiresh or
more wrong about Marlon Humphreys
probably Leighton van der ish okay yeah
Marla hump you like I liked him but you
weren't a big fan I think he was better
than the other corner exactly like I
thought they'd draft him too high like
to me I thought he was like maybe early
second like somewhere in there late and
Mannerist you just didn't see it
Leighton van der ash I really - for lack
of a better
I just thought he was a [ __ ] I did I
just didn't think he was mailed a man up
in the NFL enough that's really what it
came down to me I saw the athleticism I
just said damn I don't know if this
guy's willing to be in car crashes on a
regular basis yeah
and he's proving me wrong all right now
we need to talk about mahomes against
the Ravens team give it to me you said
to me mahomes his ability to hit wide
receivers who are covered and put it in
a spot where only they can get it is
incredible I would say it's luck if he
didn't do it three times a week yeah
it's unbelievable there's just a few
plays there was one where he was kind of
like scrambled who was left
they were playing like two men they were
all over Travis Kelsey Kelsey he's got a
defender between him he's turning almost
a look at my homes as he's throwing it
but my homes just goes that he's in a
weird spot I think if I throw a laser
just real high up to where Travis Kelce
can extend his arms and catch it he'll
catch it and that guy
be able to make a play on it and he just
throws it there and I would say it's
luck most times if it weren't done on a
weekly basis by this guy
you showed us on Monday night yeah the
throat at Tyreke hill right where Tyree
kill was when mahomes released it right
now you're telling me that he can kind
of figure out where it can go where only
his guy can get it yeah it sounds like a
sixth sense yeah he's a he is like it's
not just a is it's not just physical a
pillow no he's a natural it's all I
always say that like that's that's my
phrase from what I'm saying like what
you're saying right he's a natural like
it's just the balls in his hand he's got
an ax knack about feeling the rush about
where I should put my arm to throw this
one where you know oh this guy's really
well covered but the DB is not looking
at me so I can throw it in a spot and
feel that he's not gonna make a play on
it cuz he doesn't really see me how many
quarterbacks are even noticing if a DB
isn't looking like of the 32 starting
quarterbacks yeah how many of him excuse
me can read a DB yeah and how many of
them are already pre deciding where
they're gonna go and they're kind of
looking at the formation they're kind of
yeah to me only the really good ones can
take little nuances like that like
everybody can see it and you might have
your day here and there where you go
okay I really have seen it good but like
like Baker Mayfield can do it he can do
the same thing okay Tom of course can do
it Tom can go oh damn they're doubling
Gronk yeah but none of them are looking
at me I'm just gonna throw this the spot
where Gronk and get it and throw it like
I am NOT an anti Kirk Cousins guy yeah
but I don't think Kirk Cousins is
noticing that new one probably not no
probably not not to the degree they are
on a play-by-play basis like that's
that's you know again natural stuff I
was like Baker Tom Rogers they can kind
of just feel it and go oh I got nothing
there but I know that guy's head's not
looking at me let me just throw it out
there and put it in a spot look those
are the guys that are smiling a lot
exactly those are the guys that are
having fun out there those are the guys
or smacking people's asses and having a
great time right you can see that right
and you said that no-look pass was cool
but the next throw was even more Kohli
crap I have I don't even know what
you're talking about I mean the next
pass was the side all
I'm running to the left and I think I'm
going to scramble and run oh wait my
back's running up the sideline and
there's a hole how was the play yeah
that was the next play there's a hole
three feet big let me throw it like I'm
a shortstop running it deep into the
hole and just flick it through there to
the first baseman and that's what it
looked like it's just like to me where
I'm just like what the like are you
kidding me like most quarterbacks are
like let me get my shoulder straight let
me set my feet and he's just like ass
and I like that you say that he can use
his arm as an independent contractor
when necessary he can he's got that kind
of arm some people do it to a fault he
uses it for fun yeah yeah when he has to
when he knows he's that talented to just
go okay I'm all screwed up but a damn
I'm so good I can I can figure this out
and make it happen
on the other side Ravens offense Chiefs
defense you said the big thing that you
overlooked was the Ravens wide receivers
really aren't that scary
so the Chiefs weren't afraid to play men
they were not not as much a side that
was if I had a self Scout self there
that would be my one thing I would lose
John Brown not scary if he was scared
yeah he's not scary like he was that for
I don't feel like he ever regained his
speed after he had some of those like
earlier this year he was have a past but
he's not like how do I want to say this
left go he's not physical fast okay he's
what yeah I know the new one I'm making
this up this is something like my dad
might know what I'm talking about when
we talk about this he's fast when
nobody's touching them and everything's
good but when somebody puts a hand on
him it changes ever it changes
everything or pits him in the hip or he
had a get the guy at the line of
scrimmage and got bumped just as he was
getting going here it's just not like
we're Adele and Julio those guys can
just go ed didn't really bother me I'm
still going see the most physically fast
receiver
I mean Julio can just run company Julio
is like it would probably be the head of
that list right you know and like juju
is very special yet even feelings good
at like that those time or yeah that's
like that's the physically elite there
and that you wrote so many times in your
notes that the Ravens were better in was
it 21 personnel or 31 personnel or maybe
well 12 14 yeah 12 and 13 it sounds like
from your notes the Ravens are best off
to put more tight ends on the field than
Crabtree and Sneed
I I think so I think they just need you
know one of them on the field yeah where
if they put two of them on the field
that's great but to me they're wasting
time when they get into three wide
receiver sets not what they are it's not
the greatest strength a little more it's
not the greatest strength of their
offensive coordinator Marty morningway I
think they're at their best when they
really put you in a bind because you're
in a bind when you play the Ravens
already because you go dim their old
line is so big what are we going to do
right and because if we spread out yeah
it takes it and Gus Edwards punching us
in the face exactly right so to me they
could go this is where I think it would
help it's gonna help the passing game
because the play actions and boots once
again you're gonna you get two and three
tight end sets people are gonna pack it
in there even more here for Lamar and
it's gonna make it easier for Lamar even
on his run plays to go oh here's the
fake up the middle - Gus Edwards you all
are in there because of the three Texas
exactly right you said that Lamar played
well yeah except for the sack fumble
from Justin Houston but it wasn't
entirely his fault but more overall
about Lamar yeah did you think he played
I like where is he at us develop I mean
it's it's Lamarche trending in the right
direction I mean I think his
decision-making some of the throws he
makes are they're damn good you know
there was a throw or two that were
complete over the middle that might have
been a little behind but they were
complete nonetheless
but another guy that I look at that just
go you know he does have a natural feel
for the game he really does he knows how
to move in the pocket even when it
doesn't look like he's looking at the
pocket but he justs little mover a
subtle dip of the arm whatever it may be
can get stuck on the first read still
too long a time yeah but I think it's
all going in the really quickly Lamar
had one of the best quotes at a press
conference ever today reporter said
you're now starting Joe Flacco is going
to be the backup does it feel like your
team and the more responded with it's
not my team it's our team I don't block
anybody I don't catch any passes I don't
run any balls it's our team see and it
was like
okay that's good Lamar's the man he is
the man hey is the man and I just think
with the Ravens too they have good tight
ends
yeah Mark Andrews max Williams came her
taint Hurst they just drafted Boyle yes
they have four tight ends like to me
that would be their they were a
nightmare but they're great for real
right and to me those guys can be like
again I said this I think a little I can
remember who I said this about last week
either way they could play like that New
England game of the old days where they
go we got two Titans in the field we
might smash Matthew but then if you're
getting too confident on the stopping
the run we can spread it out with these
two tight ends and they can run some of
the routes we need to be run I got two
games I want to go quickly before we get
to fill in about eleven minutes okay
Patriots offense Dolphins defense yeah
the number one theme that I kept seeing
summed up by this yeah you're not gonna
hear me say this much but the Patriots
ran the ball too much yeah
yeah they the you said they played
phenomenal they played phenomenal but
they ran too much yeah the Patriots
offense was they were unstoppable
through the game
Miami was determined not to let the run
game beat that so they must have been
listening to the podcast day I guess so
they sold out to stop the run they were
not gonna ever be outnumbered in the run
game schemes and when I say outnumbered
I mean if there's five linemen a tight
end and a fullback okay so that gives
you seven blockers Miami was gonna have
seven guys in the box if not eight they
were gonna make sure like no we're not
gonna get out numbered in this situation
to where now you have a good scheme and
we don't have enough people to get that
you thought the Patriots could a more
play action because they were loaded
yeah I just think every time they drop
back for a play-action it was 15y want a
just do more I don't know why I really
don't have an answer for you I you know
sometimes I think as a play caller you
get lost in the game too and you have
all these plays you've worked on during
the week and you lose sight a little bit
yeah ago I mean like oh what really
worked for us here maybe they wanted to
stay with the run because they didn't
have any faith from their defense top in
the know but maybe they didn't let's get
to that which operates offense Patriots
D my first question is I didn't
understand this word yeah you wrote
Miami's first big run Patriots playing
like a red
oh not up not like a redneck that would
be my family from Kentucky and myself we
are rednecks what is that word I didn't
read it
reduced oh I was saying a reduced under
so okay just to explain to everybody out
there you know they usually play the
bear front kind of cover the three guys
in the middle they do it a lot right a
guy over the GAR to go over the center a
guy over the girl exactly right three on
three football in the middle for some
reason in this game and a few times it
happened especially on the first big
gore run the nose tackle was shaded to
the left shoulder of instead of right
over instead of right over into the left
shoulder the center and instead of the
next guy being on the guards outside
shoulder their tackle and yeah like he's
more like not head up on the guard but
just slightly to the edge of the guard
so this had close together this time he
was like in the gap between the guard
and the tackle right instead of like
what would it like we're usually if you
have the nose shaded that way the next
guy is then head up on the tackle right
and that's what I meant by a reduced
under so he wasn't head up on the tackle
he was down a little bit in between the
guard and the tackle okay and so it
wasn't a true bear front and there was a
few times in the game why I wrote this
where the Dolphins had the right scheme
but dialed up and there was no way like
on that play specifically and like two
or three others there's no way the the
Patriots could stop it there's just no
way you wrote Tannehill on fire he's on
the money tenant Hill I mean not a lot
of easy throws throughout the game may
he plays well against the patron man he
does I mean again he's probably another
guy we need to give more credit to in
general you heard me talk about this a
little yesterday I did yeah but no I
mean you just start thinking about this
yourself man oh I didn't exactly okay
but I had some text message
conversations with some people but I do
think it's true nonetheless I mean he's
12 and one in his last 13 games as a
starter yeah I mean that's pretty damn
good
we I just not I see this were true
Biscay along yeah when you played some
why
receiver right you will be called an
athlete your entire career right now 10
L also had Miko Grimes which was Brent
Grimes his wife yes his number one hater
right I haven't heard her talking about
Jameis Winston yet but that's cool
that's interesting yes but no but she
was saying that he's an athlete he'll
never be a good quarterback and a lot of
people clung on to that yeah and I
understood it because for a while
sometimes I still don't know if Ryan
Tannehill is good but he made a lot of
great throws in that game that a nice
little deep pass distills was beautiful
right the touchdown a Bryce Butler was
an absolutely blow the money yeah I know
he does well where is your honest
evaluation my honest evaluation gonna be
a free agent yeah I know my honest
evaluation of him is like yes he is a
middle of the NFL quarterback he's never
to me going to be a superstar I don't
think I don't think he's they like got
any true elite trait about him to be a
superstar but I would also say there's
no glaring weakness to his game either
he does everything pretty well moves
pretty well plays with size in the
pocket good arm straight exactly can
make all the throws you might know why
you were drop your jaw he's tough played
play with that whole ankle if lemon can
run the read option we saw that do that
on the first drive he ripped off a 13
yard run so to me he's one of those guys
where the fan base is always gonna go
man I mean I think we could do better
I see Carson Wentz out there I see my
home's and DeSean to think like an adder
like Jack you're not sure but you draft
somebody and then they get in there and
you go dim they're not as good as Renton
Tannehill dak Mariota like true Biscay
like they're all in this same thing
where if they run for 120 the articles
come out about how they're this
incredible weapon if they throw four to
ten and two picks he's more of a wide
receiver than he is a great right he's
an ass he's an athlete he's playing
quarterback right Bucs offense Saints
defense yeah so again buck started this
game up 14 to 3 but all of your notes
you were never concerned at all yeah you
said that the Saints defense was great
but the thing that stood out to me was
cam Jordan Sheldon Rankin's Marcus
Davenport all have moments of being
unblockable yes they do
they're there that is the gift of their
defense their front for saves them for
me with my evaluation or just things I
see you know they they have basically
got into a little bit like we said with
I said with Chicago where they just go
we're not gonna sell out to stop the run
we're not gonna sell out to bullets all
the time and do that we have a good
front for we're gonna let them handle it
we're not gonna bite on play-action pass
and then you know the quarterback comes
out of the fake and there's seven guys
at the line of scrimmage and there's
nobody deep down the field so you
believe the better defenses don't react
as much to play action because they have
more faith that they're d-line could
stop the run yeah because that's what
you wrote about the Bears - yeah so when
you have a really good D line
play-action doesn't work as much exactly
and so that's why for the rams and
saints who live on play-action they've
had trouble with those defenses
interesting right and then what I was
the other thing that does it off of that
well we don't have to compromise or
secondary a lot of times if there's a
situation we just hey we got seven guys
back in coverage and we're just gonna
trust our phone four to get there we
don't know what they're gonna call here
when they get in this set they're
dangerous here so let's err on being you
know safe and just let the front four
get there but that's it is amazing there
d-line it's one of the un-- talked about
this football yeah because there's no
real superstar but there's a lot of good
and the depth is just yeah it's not just
Jordan rankings and Devon no it's not
it's you know it's Okafor it's
stallworth when he gets in there I mean
Davison starts you know it's it's they
have a nice group of guys there eight
nine deep and that's the one thing I
think we've continued to see over the
last few years they're really good
defenses in football it's more than six
or seven deep it's got to be eight or
nine deep at the defensive line
especially to stop some of these high
octane octane offenses you got to be
able to throw up versatility in your D
line oh we got to get small oh we got to
get big and then you got to be able to
throw fresh bodies at these high octane
offenses so they can continue to rush
the passer and be like totally intensity
high you were impressed with the Bucks D
lineman to you
and you said jpp Gerald McCoy and vida
Vega yeah we're pretty damn good they're
pretty damn good haven't heard one
sentence about vita vega in any NFL
content i didn't even know he was play
yeah i mean it just happened a few weeks
ago and the first few weeks I was gonna
like bring him up but he like wasn't
totally a hundred percent healthy and
what does he say he is is he better than
Danny Shelton yes he's more athletic
than Danny Shelton okay that's what you
see right away and I don't even think
we're seeing our best football with him
it to the him next I got the true
evaluation will come next year when he
gets a true training camp yeah it
doesn't have the thrown it back into the
fold of things week eight of the season
that's hard but their size is I mean
it's mind-blowing they can do some of
the things we just talked about with the
Saints Carl NASA balls exactly right
Carl now your bear you know yeah Bo Alan
Vinny Vinny curry carries a big dude to
again they did the same thing a little
bit hey miss Alice oh yeah and they just
said we're gonna trust our front for
yeah well let you stop the run we're not
gonna let up you big pass plays it's the
second week in a row that you said that
someone took this BS Saints play away
yeah and the big line and I'm gonna open
up my at mentions you wrote Brees can't
make a play right yeah Brees just just
two weeks in a row where he we've seen
like you know I don't and when I say
make a play listen I know he can hit
throws and things like that
I'm talking about when nothing's there
nothing right
like Patrick mahomes scrambling on
fourth down or Patrick mahomes throwing
a sidearm ball or whatever it is I'm
just talking about and those five or six
plays a game where there's nothing the
receivers are on lockdown the pass
protections okay but it's not great
you're gonna slide and move and make a
throw like that's he straw it struggles
Ville when that happens and and yes when
you take it we've seen for the second
week in row when you take away some of
their cute plays they've had a hard time
throwing the ball consistently with with
success
alright awesome stuff on the film
notebook this week Sims oh one other
thing too you know what I want we didn't
talk about this at the rams okay
I know you're rolling your eyes she's
like damn Ito no I'm
trying to figure out what I skipped over
no it's nothing huge
the Rams as much as I liked Nick you can
call him yeah we're gonna do as much as
I liked there D and how I said is game
plan wise I don't know if you saw a few
times they wrote I don't know how they
stopped this play in this alignment
right so they just sometimes aligned in
ways where I go I don't know how you get
you what you wrote one you go if Aaron
Donnell doesn't make that tackle this
old buddy does right like he's gone
they're just hey there big [ __ ] yes
but that was my only thing there is just
like there's times where the Bears ran
weakside runs between the guard and the
tackle okay to the right side and the
linebackers are so kicked over to the
left
I want to go damn how are they supposed
to stop this run between the tackle and
the guard you know what they did what
they did I'll hold on one second down
with David a few times is the guard
blocked down on you know whoever was the
shade knows time there and the center
pulled around and now the tackle walks
like five yards waiting for every
linebacker to come through to pursue now
as he comes to the second level so and
there's another your mind it was
somewhat of a base like it wasn't as
aggressive yeah the alignments are still
like why are we doing yeah there's just
little things with it it was a good
start for the Rams defense but yeah they
have moments where I go I don't
understand this alignment and how they
can even stop or think of stopping this
play with the way they're aligned so
those last thing sorry hey Dad
that's okay I knew you were talking
about the Bears Rams game and it was it
was a mob woman it was right a butt
whooping well yeah wise but I the plays
you're talking about yeah they lined up
and listen if you watch a lot of tape on
the Rams you will see things like that
quite often you will you've definitely
well yeah I've been I've been begging
them to be more simple on defense like
saying that they have aggressive players
as is they don't need to be a team that
runs 12 different defenses no they don't
you know a lot of things you're right
there make it simple Aqib Talib is back
he's playing himself play back into
shape
right it'll be a big deal is they go
along and and you know one game is just
like I am now getting ready to watch the
Giants and the Bears play from two weeks
ago because they're gonna talk of his
Giants this weekend and I refused to
watch the Giants play to watch the
Redskins that was like what was that why
I was sad was touch football right did
you guys see the clip though of say
qualm Barkley talking to his offensive
line and then having the 80-yard run
like two plays later I have not seen
that I didn't see it but hey Tom there's
this clip where he's like standing over
his offensive line he tells the center
he goes if you hook this guy looks to
the guard he goes if you hook that guy I
can set it up and when I hit that hole I
don't have to worry about the safety cuz
he's gonna kind of shade one way and
then the very next like time to go out
there is that 80 yard touchdown and then
say Quan puts us home on the bed she
goes that's exactly what I said that's
exactly how I said it was gonna go
it's so awesome he's never that is that
is football porn look if I'm a Giants
fan I would just watch that over and
over again be like oh man like this is
hot well that's pretty advanced stuff
really for the rookie running back I
mean look here's a running back and it's
the same at all levels just about they
read this that whatever but to say that
that's pretty cool it really is he's the
best running back in the NFL sell well
I'm not going to disagree just the he
truly is somebody I I would have bet
money I should have pulled this back a
little that he was going to have at
least two 80 yard touchdown runs this
year yeah and you know I said I should I
should have made it like 60 or 65
because you know he's gonna make these
great long runs if they'd have been
backed up more they would have been 80
yarders but he's you know but you could
just tell by the number of tackles he
breaks and how hard he is to break down
and the moves that he can make right you
know just going from one side to the
other just a jump cut whatever you want
to call it yeah I mean that was easy to
see even back when the Giants won the
beginning a year when their offensive
line was horrendous right he was making
great white to yard runs there were
tremendous right and
so it's he's turned out to be everything
and more and yes to agree with you Adam
best running back in football because
it's just what I said there and also
because he can catch the football yeah
right nobody does more of a less than
say Kwan can we put your dad to work
right now yeah let's put him to work you
gotta do something oh my god so we
normally spend a little time talking
about the Thursday Night Football game
for this podcast that comes out
Wednesday because Thursday's game is so
special
I'd like a sim Sims breakdown we got
Chiefs we got Chargers we got mahomes
Tyreke Hill and has been announced he
will be playing Spencer where is
doubtful Sammy Watkins is going to be
out for the Chargers Austin Eckler is
going to be out Melvin Gordon's going to
be questionable it's in Kansas City and
I'm curious Phil what's your what's your
initial feeling this is a huge game ten
and two verses eleven and three let's
see what's the weather forecast that you
hear now let me aspirin let me ask
whether boy give me a second I'll pull
it up yeah that'll be interesting you
know just I just want to make sure the
games not going to be played in like you
know Amaya soon or something isn't a
monsoon who does that benefit
that's a good question probably can't
City teeth I think so yes I think
mahomes first and foremost is we laughed
about on the air Lisa candy contains
he's what a proof hmm you know the
motion everything he does in his arm and
all that shows me he's weather proof
where you know and and I would say
Philip Rivers is pretty close to that
too though the way he throws he throws
sidearm you know he's not the guy that
loses control of the ball very seldom
yeah rain during the day cloudy at night
32 degrees risk yep could be a slippery
field probably not okay well I don't
even know where to begin I know this the
Baltimore Ravens lined up and just
smashed the ball at that Kansas City
defense and it was pretty awesome it was
an awesome game I don't know where to
start with this game let's start let's
start with that
here we go yeah you're looking at a
receiving core of the chargers that is
as good as anybody in NFL I would guess
I mean Christopher you agree with that
yeah I mean I think from like one
through four I would say yes I'm not
going to say it's the top duo but yeah I
think they're a very it's amazing and we
see the Kansas City Chiefs are going to
have trouble recovering one through four
when you talk about what they do very
much yeah and the other thing is to when
you look at the Chiefs get good pass
rushers Chris Jones has done a great job
inside Justin Houston you know deep Ford
D Ford's kind of fallen off the map here
of late I didn't even notice him in the
game I didn't watch it on tape but I
didn't notice him in the Baltimore game
but you know a lot of things favor
the Chargers when I say that but I just
look at this and mahomes is such a
wild-card factor in everything that
protecting don't protect him get open
don't get open
does it matter he is going to make plays
in other words he's got to make them
when they're open he's going to move and
make plays and those are things that you
just can't account for no matter who
that what defense you're playing and I
and it's that's why I'm gonna lean
towards the Kansas City teams that's why
I'm gonna take them in the game and it's
the main reason is strictly Patrick
mahomes now the offensive line
Christopher and you to tell me about
this when you had them when y'all look
at it did you think the Kansas City line
blocked Baltimore Ravens very well in
the passing Department well after
reading your son's notes of watching the
film
it sounded like wink mr. Martindale for
the Ravens kind of knew all the slides
and protections and was able to take
advantage of it but you also wrote a lot
Simms that the Ravens just did all out
blitzes all the time yeah I mean that
that was to me the Ravens I just I don't
know how you felt about it I don't even
know if you watched it on film yet but I
did I I wrote down all the numbers and
everything there is in my notebook
downstairs the rain down the number of
blitzes I wrote down the number of blitz
zones how many times they play
man-to-man and I'm
Tam's he played zone because I was
curious and I was surprised at how much
they did coming out to the quarterback
yeah that's that was my number one thing
I we kind of just went through my film
breakdown stuff and I just
I did not realize watching on TV how
aggressively the Ravens played
especially just putting people at the
line of scrimmage bringing people to
blitz and pressure more times than not
and you know Kansas City the West Coast
often said they are there are a slide
protection team right so the back might
be offset to the right and then they
slide the offense offensive line to the
left and Baltimore knew that and some of
their sets where they were like oh well
we'll show like we're gonna blitz to the
side they're gonna slide too but then at
the last second we're gonna come out and
come the other way to where they're not
sliding the way we're actually bringing
the pressure so yeah I mean but can the
Chargers do you get questioned yeah
don't they don't take care to protect a
lot you know like what are you saying my
counter protect well just but you know
the back go across the formation do
whatever we you know so that way they
can't get a read off the linemen if the
back is offset over here they're gonna
slide this way yes they will do that
right to go oh I made backs offset to
the right we always slide to the left
well we'll change it up and slide to the
right in the back to the left
I'm just saying I think wink had a beat
on what certain formations which way
Andy typically likes the slide that's
all you know I mean he'll say that I got
confused
not confused but I got tricked because I
was watching I saw Martin Del's press
conference and I was reading something
as close I said I got it he's just gonna
let his four guys keep him in the pocket
they're gonna play some zone make him
throw some tight window throws they got
good defensive backs all you got to do
is tip the ball I was so sure I got it
this is it and then they they play the
game and there you go god I want him
close it was it tells you something and
also it was it made when I watched the
game I came away with this feeling to
the Baltimore Ravens defense is more
athletic than I gave it credit for to
write you know I thought
front especially you know za'darius
smith and just he had a guy thought he
was all over at everyday you know
beating you know kids said he's got a
good offensive line and they did a good
job of just really beating them up
physically they won the battle on both
sides of the football
and it took a miracle for him to lose
that's how you got to look at it
physically Baltimore won the game on
both sides of the ball in my eyes but my
homes you know the yep the wrong throw
on fourth down to Tyree kill and you
were right Christopher did you see
Showtime last night I did not yet know
okay bill you never watch that's okay I
do to shut up all right
but Adam I took four plays out of the
game because Ray Lewis goes well they
made the mistake I go alright we could
do it about every play no but you don't
understand so we always have these
arguments on Showtime and it's pretty
good right so I picked out some plays
and I told you about the sorry go ahead
plays it what do you do right so we
would show the play reg as well come on
you know the boy and he had it read with
him to was so I was getting
double-teamed I was getting slapped
around like I was curling the Three
Stooges and and and they were right to
them
all the movement that fake in the
reverses that go come on I can tell you
every time what it's gonna be so the
play we're talking about the touchdown
that he throws at the end of the game
where there's a bunch right right where
Weddell blitz right and I thought I had
him I said okay here's a play here we're
lined up what are you gonna do and he
goes well CJ's got the running back I
said yeah but if he crosses home
formation they have a call and they got
the call and the call is you pull the
blitz off and you take him right and I
go okay you were they thought that was
like so simple that you can't it's like
we put this in like the first day of
training camp I know their idea simple
is not as simple as the and I said to
somebody today
I said listen Ray Lewis and Ed Reid you
could say whatever you want about them
yeah they are so smart yeah on the
defensive side so they just they you
know raise always argued about today's
offense you can't believe how stupid the
defensive players are they chase
everything and that's all this is Phil
Phil we got some we got some
late-breaking news Oh Eric Berry is
officially playing on Thursday Night
Football okay yes I was expecting they
kept saying they were gonna get him out
to this week so will that make a big
difference Adam I hope it does long term
just because I've been so underwhelmed
by the Chiefs ability to play coverage
on the back end then it kind of like
increases the depth where maybe Orlando
Scandrick doesn't have to be on an
island as much yeah but a safety because
I look at the Chiefs and I go if d4 can
turn it back on Chris Jones is one of
the best defensive linemen the entire
NFL if you can get at least one guy back
there
that's a playmaker I just think that
defense needs something yeah I would be
really shocked if he could be a
playmaker right away yeah he needs these
three games just to get ready so he
could have an impact in the playoffs
right I think it's really interesting
when you look at week one of Chiefs
chargers and you realize that the
Chargers actually out gain the Chiefs
541 to 362 yeah and if you remember back
Tyrell Williams dropped that touchdown
the end zone there were two really big
drops in that game right yeah it was a
it was a close game we remember them a
wholeness for touchdowns
we remember the ant the Spencer touched
down over the the slant to Tyree kill
where he took it the whole way the
Chargers the Chargers scored 28 they
could have scored 45 the Chargers my two
minutes of not there one-minute synopsis
on this game
the Chargers should be able to move the
ball on the Kansas City Chiefs all night
now the only thing that's gonna hurt
them a little bit is the fact that
Eckler doesn't sound like easy to play
it doesn't sound like Gordon's gonna
play these questions so get Kansas City
I think would air on going okay we might
not have to stop the run in some of
these situations that we normally would
but either way I would have a hard time
thinking that Phillip Rivers in that
pass offense don't they move the ball
like at will I'm officially playing Mike
Williams okay so dad and jump jump in
here any time you think I know what
about the other side so then the other
side of the ball okay here's the biggest
weakness to the Chargers defense in my
opinion they're small they're too small
they're they're ridiculously small what
do you mean up I mean Damien's square is
a 290-pound nose tackle they play one
middle linebacker and it's jeté beyond
Browns devious prey right he's the only
linebacker in the game a lot of the time
Wow Phillips at the other linebacker
position the safety from poison they
like to play the three seat these guys
driving James they play Adrian Phillips
a little I died right exactly and I love
three safeties in the field till they
run at you and you realize I don't care
how strong you are how fast you are
that's 120 pound lineman hits a hundred
put in 85 or 200-pound right safety you
don't hang in there and the dispenser
wears not in right are they gonna be
able to pound them well I like Damien
Williams enough to go he should be okay
so that would be the key to the game
though I don't know for it like to me
Kansas City just gotta run the ball
enough they just kind of run it enough
because it because to me you know it is
gonna be San Diego is gonna only worry
about the past they're probably gonna be
going oh gosh we hope Bosa and Ingram
can get pressure off the edge we don't
want to compromise and do something on
the back end to leave anybody one-on-one
with Tyreke or anything like that but
what they can do to the Chargers and
what happened to the Chargers in
Cincinnati last week is they started to
run the ball and then the charger start
to run bullets to because they go
we can't block them man-to-man or we
can't stop the running Amanda man so we
got to create yeah we got to create
chaos then to stop the run and that's
what we've gone through and that's
dangerous against games all the
Pittsburgh Steelers light up against the
Chargers and let them to listen yeah the
Chargers won yes there was one thumb
right they were lucky right I said this
to you last week I think when they lined
up on the field when the camera once
went to the sidelines I went Jesus yeah
you said this to me privately not a lot
but yeah you're right how much bigger
Pittsburgh is
then the Chargers yeah right so that was
one thing that jumped out and of course
all the breaks went to Chargers way and
now they're gonna be playing in Kansas
City it's not the first game of the year
it's not warm weather and I don't care
Philip Rivers has thrown the ball he's
thrown it well they do that but this
will be a whole different atmosphere
throwing the football
it won't travel the same way he's not
going to get the same grip it's you know
there's it's it's just going to be
different in that respect yes I think
the Kansas City offensive line after the
job they did against the Baltimore
Ravens that is going to be motivation
and they know this Chargers defensive
line and what they do and the charges do
not do a lot of stuff on defense either
so you know they do more
I'll give them Gus Bradley a little
credit and right they're doing more but
these alignments these different guys up
in there and Damian Williams you know
look he's an NFL running back he's had
success in the league and no matter who
the running back just for Kansas City
they're not going to feature him right
if they do cream on he was featured yeah
because they want to throw it to him
also so I think the it was a great
wake-up call for the Kansas City Chiefs
last week and I really do expect him to
play well in the game Phil I'm gonna ask
you to do one mean one more favor I am
starting to get sick and if you could
take me back to your time in Kentucky
are there any natural remedies that you
think I could take right now in Phil
Simms as medicine box natural remedies
yeah like what like how did you how do
you handle getting sick Phil Simms well
I got a little cold right now okay so
I'm here at my desk all day Wednesday is
my day to do nothing but just sit here
and I do I
it's brutal sitting in this chair but I
drink green tea green tea green juice a
natural honey and I know the brand of
green tea that you would recommend well
what do you think I would say that a
nice glass of Bigelow green
decaffeinated of course because I don't
want to you know be buzzing up here
burning enough injury and I put this I
forgot the name of the honey but I put
that in it to sweeten it up a little and
I take tremendous amounts of
Mindi vitamin D D so you just drinking
milk or you're taking actual vitamins I
take vitamins yes nice
his skin hasn't seen the Sun in a decade
so he needs an item nd in his body and I
think I take an extraordinary amount and
for the first time in probably five
years I went to a doctor I took the
blood test he goes Wow your vitamin D is
almost normal you know almost my god but
so that's eight listen what's the
greatest thing for not feeling well Adam
leap sleep brother okay take whatever it
is I'm not gonna get into that take what
you got to take make sure you sleep ten
hours at least and you I slept 10 hours
last night wow that's like a coma oh my
god yeah all right I also died like you
guys but I'm not a great sleeper the
night before I want to do a lot of work
no I mean either trust me I'm yeah it's
it's it's you gotta get your work done
and feel good about it as early as
possible so you can quit thinking about
it
damn as tonight as I make all my NFL
picks tonight I don't usually get to
sleep into like - oh God yeah I go
through all the games I ham and haw
about the lines well I had that we have
to pick damn games yesterday I mean come
on Tuesday I'm like going
who's playing I don't even know who
played this weekend I yeah I really do
get confused yeah all right because
you're one week runs in the other and
you pick games
Oh what's Wednesday so you're gonna have
to put your games out tomorrow yeah yeah
exactly
alright we're done with you what we have
no more use for you you teabagger you
yeah yeah that's right hey so goober
Murr on Showtime what I took a sip about
I'm just gonna remind everybody to get
that gift you teabagging yourself is
incredible the string gets caught in
between my teeth and and we weren't
filming at the time but the camera is
always rolling so they roll it in the
show they think it's funny and we ever
laugh so the next week Christopher
you've seen them and you Rin one of them
one of the Bigelow lads
I take this big board that I have a
Bigelow T with me in it
and I say to Chris College oh that's it
Chris look what I got because a bad team
egg they got stuck among teeth and he
goes are you kidding me
that's unbelievable yeah yeah I got a
three-year deal and it don't think and
he bought it that's great
he bought it I mean man we used I poured
more I poured more stunts on Chris
Cosworth he had every to even buys them
all it was great so oh well hey Adam I'm
with you I'm a little out of the weather
but you know what we're going to rally
we're gonna roll and we're gonna get it
done brother
awesome gee Joe yeah I'm seeing this
right here from the sports Business
Journal back at May 1st 2006 t42
father-and-son sims will tout bigelow
brand yes with a quote from super agent
Steve Rosner the family aspect of this
is what makes it work yeah that was my
first major marketing deal as I was a
starting quarterback for the fantasy
thing it's probably right around the
same time I started going back to blood
donation commercials in Tampa yes that
was after I lost my spleen and the blood
actually saved my life so yes perfect
coach that was pretty good for me to
speak up for that quick discussions now
that we've already done Chargers chiefs
I thought about it I think George
Kindles the best tight end in the NFL I
think that he's a better blocker than
Travis Kelce and I think he could do
more after the catch than Travis Kelce
everything I saw from Gronk in the Miami
game I think that speaks for where he is
at this point yeah Kronk's really good
still though of course but I had owns a
better blocker for sure
I think George Kittel might be the best
tide in the NFL right now ah because he
what he can do in line is much better
than what Zach Hertz can do
definitely definitely I think that
Kittel and Kelsey would probably be my
one to two Kendall is the better blocker
than Kelsey you're definitely right
about that I don't know if I would say
Kittles faster straightaway that's what
I'm sure sure - Kelsey's a better
receiver he's a better route runner
receiver type 5050 balls I'm covered let
me
jump up and catch I think he's better -
adjusting the ball and doing things like
that over kettle so it's different it's
always hard to tell with like I'll is so
good at scheming for the tight end coach
- where he can get you in spots to make
you look like you're he-man at times
yeah um but I think that's a healthy
debate I'll tell you the other toy that
I'm gonna throw in that debate you know
who I like is baby grump
Oh Vance McDonald I think Vance McDonald
is like not quite in their class I
didn't even notice any big plays but
he's the next guy yeah I don't know if
he had any big plays against Oakland
either way but to me he is a force
because it's a Ian Thomas no I mean he's
going he is he's going in the right
direction but yeah Vance McDonald is one
of my favorites because he has taken
over the role of Gronk where when he
catches the ball in the middle of the
field he is looking to punish people I'm
just gonna make you think is Shanahan
making George Kittel or is Kittel making
Shanahan your blips and then Josh sent
me this article about Ryan Tannehill
storing stem cells in the Cayman Islands
you heard about this no I think I have
some so what what exactly was that we're
storing stem cells in our family this is
perfect okay let me let me read the
tanis's what Josh was hoping for so this
came out yesterday and this is from an
article Miami Dolphins quarterback Ryan
Tannehill revealed in a video Tuesday he
has a secret stash squared away
squirreled away in the Cayman Islands
instead of an offshore bank account to
protect his wealth
Tannehill said he has thousands of stem
cells stored in a Cayman Islands lab in
case he needs them to recover from an
injury quote things are gonna be hurting
a little bit when I'm older it's the
nature of the business so to have
something available to help heal from
that is huge whether it's an injury in
practice or I tweaked something during
the offseason or 20 years after my
career is done I have these cells cells
banked and grant came in and I'm able to
use those in order to improve my quality
of life and enjoy the rest of my life
right it's interesting so why don't you
couldn't store them in America though
like Miami there's no place that can do
that so I don't understand any of this
well Stan it also makes me go is this
another thing that I'm not saving like
should I have been saving stem cells no
it's not you what is
you could like well stem cells are
things like if you have issues later on
down your life something physically that
they can use like your own DNA structure
to kind of help your body out in
whatever ways that may be so like I know
my wife so it's injecting younger you
and two older you nicely parts of you or
and where they can maybe magnify there
or help it or do anything thirst is
proven to help people
I'm een yes yes this is true science
proven yes and what do you do with it so
no I know because I think you can use it
I gotta get this story straight from my
wife cuz this is definitely her
department but like I know my kids we
have like stem cells saved from them
from their birth and like you could save
listen like the placenta umbilical cords
yeah and I think even I can use it
because it has like my DNA in there too
but wait so do you have stem cells of
yourself saved so I don't know if I do
mind whether you tap it in you spring
cancer or rehabilitation things and so
just by introducing younger yeah they
can find ways of like right like if you
had to get you know anything like even
like muscle repair anything they can
inject these things into you I gotta go
straight to like me yes there's
legitimate science behind it from what I
know and I obviously don't know the
whole story but a synopsis Ryan
Tannehill storing of stem cells I mean
sure my note he's got the money to do it
he's fine so that would be my follow-up
questions how much does it cost us I
don't know that's another things they
don't ask my wife no I don't even want
to know the answer to how many commas I
don't know but I'm sure it's expensive
because my wife just comes with the word
expensive her name should be Danielle
expensive since we're thinking like
hundred thousand don't think that okay
no well I'd like to be stronger and I
have more faith in your stem cells than
mine
yeah can I check some of yours me well
it's like then all of a sudden my arm
will be I don't think it I don't think
it takes to that I don't know you know I
I'm gonna I'm actually texting my wife
as we're sitting here just while you do
that right I think we check on this fly
oh yeah let's do it you want to do it no
okay you're the one that laid the trap
alright so okay so we do have stem cells
he's right there he's hanging on to life
in the hot chocolates still moving well
I would say this is there a better way
to go than drowning in hot chocolate in
a way we Willy Wonka this for fly we did
this fly fell into a chocolate stream
and drowned in essence we're all Willy
Wonka's were the two of us you're Willy
do I want to say you're Willy today with
your purple sweatshirt on okay it's true
so with that in mind I just want to say
to the entire cast how do I I gotta feel
like going anyway I kind of feel bad for
him now oh yeah it's not great he's
swimming he's swimming all right I would
just like to say to the entire cast of
Survivor that is stem cells from the
umbilical cords okay okay yes this you
know that we're talking about this on
the podcast ball no but you will later
all right let me do a little alarm right
here you're gonna get thirty seconds and
I'm gonna make sure that it's not the
same alarms I don't even need 30 seconds
okay I don't even need 30 seconds
congratulations thank you I just want to
say to the entire cast of this season of
Survivor this has been one of the best
seasons of Survivor in history there's
still two weeks left we got an episode
tonight if you guys want to come over
eight o'clock CBS we can all watch
together I'm okay finale is next week
it's been fantastic there's been great
gameplay a lot of backstabbing it's
never gotten personal though and I think
it's just great to see the game of
Survivor still plugging along 36 is the
best moment in this great all time year
so the first time an idol nullifier has
ever been played was this season what
does that mean so basically there are
hidden immunity idols hidden on the
island thank her pastor somehow I told
them not to do the timer so I could go
over 30 there are hidden immunity idols
hidden on the beach yeah if you find an
idol you can play it at tribal council
to save yourself if you're gonna be
voted out I've heard of that however
this year for the first time in the
history of Survivor they introduced an
idol nullifier which you basically if
you find it and I think that you Adam is
gonna play your hidden immunity idol I
can take out the idol nullifier right
Adam down put it in the urn and then if
you pull an idol out it's nullified so
you could still be eliminated so you can
still be limited does it happen it
happened you have to guess right so the
iuggage craze the odds of it working are
like
tremely minimal everybody just lose
their [ __ ] people went crazy twitter was
blowing up tribal council was blowing up
it was a really great moment and I see
his sweets 36 and I think it speaks to
the innovation of these survivor
producers that they continue to come up
with ways to change the guy I've always
believed the team's they believe us in a
second if survivor is like we just need
someone to hold the microphone he like
I'm there I yeah I would think about it
and then my only other follow-up Josh
would be out of Sims and myself who
would prefer this reason 37 between Sims
and me who would be a better survivor
participant I mean that's a really it's
a really difficult for health and
neither of us are using stem cells so
here's the thing I'm not gonna win any
of the eating challenges I'll start with
you okay yeah yeah whatever I don't make
as much as he does so that's gonna be a
strengths occasional set I'm gonna
prepare former former athletes generally
don't do well on Survivor some have made
it far is it because everyone's like he
made enough money yeah everyone's always
like he's got money in the bank he
doesn't need the million bucks let's
keep him around because he's big and
strong and he'll help us win challenges
and I use you as a blocker so basically
you're always a target I hide behind you
and I'll say let me keep Sims around so
people keep trying to get him out
they're not trying to get me out
Wow alright so you're screwed for them
yeah so you would make it you would make
it far left go yeah what's my strengths
and weaknesses you I would see being the
type of person who talks too much on the
beach tank and everyone's just like damn
this guy's talking a lot and he's not
catching for it at inception though good
at inception but I think your mouth will
work against you I see you being someone
that gets voted out just before the
merge and where does Simms get voted out
you get voted out right after the merge
because until the tribes merge its teams
so you want to keep the strong people on
your team so you keep winning but then
right after the merge every man for
himself I kick your ass to the curb as
soon as we're all on the same Beach
interesting it's just what I would do
and how do you think you would fare I of
the three of us I would fare the best I
think you know we've seen it but what if
we're on the beach my strategy for you
yeah would be I know this guy he's
schemer and he's been strategizing for
like 18 where this moment I'd beat his
ass when the cameras are off and just go
[ __ ] the cameras off on Survivor I would
be going around with like a bar of soap
and there's also no soap or towels on
Survivor oh oh then I'm out the first
day alright let's wrap up this podcast I
got about two and a half minutes on
Survivor result I don't know I'll get
more into the stem cell thing later I
blocked him out of his conversation ok I
can't take it anymore
stem cells though it's still research
that is being found right they do think
that it might be able to cure some
diseases maybe diabetes they can inject
it into the pancreas we only know what
we've learned to help but I'll find out
more for the next episode here because
I'd like to maybe save my steps right
because they're you know that's an upper
level stem cell I got you know what is
real climate change okay just how to say
that sorry thank you
forces he's out homies for food drink
good evening everybody and for this poor
fly he is swimming
I'm Adam left go the lef koe man and we
will holler at you with the pics coming
up on Friday be well be good
[Music]